Olá minhas amigas meus amigos para mais
uma live é um prazer estar aqui com
vocês me deem um feedback do áudio se
está legal se está audível se está
entendível
vamos como é de PR discutir alguns
artigos e partir paraas perguntas em
seguida do documento depois ao vivo
então o primeiro Ativ queria discutir
com vocês é um assunto an que afeta
todos nós diariamente como o horário das
nossas refeições pode impactar os níveis
de açúcar no sangue então um estudo
recente trouxe à tona algumas
descobertas surpreendentes sobre o nosso
tipo cronológico as pessoas que são os
madrugadores ou os que são os que gostam
de dormir tarde acord da tarde os
corujas né então como esse tipo de
padrão né padrão a o padrão B pode
influenciar a nossa resposta do açúcar
resposta glicêmica pós
refeições então é importante a gente
entender sobre esse assunto que pode
ajudar a melhorar nossa saúde metabólica
então um grupo de pesquisadores na
Alemanha decidiu investigar como é que o
nosso relógio biológico afeta a forma
como nós processamos os alimentos então
eles recrutaram 45 estudantes
universitários
saudáveis e submeteram
Denise tá falando que tá sem som é
isso pessoal me dê aí o feedback porque
a Denise tá falando que tá sem
som Rinaldo falou tudo
ok está normal Carlos kman tá falando
que está normal tudo bem Beleza então
voltando ao estudo é um estudo na
Alemanha que resolveu investigar como é
que o nosso relógio biológico afeta a
forma como processão dos alimentos então
eles recrutaram 45 estudantes
universitários saudáveis submeteram a
eles um experimento os participantes
consumiram refeições com alto índice
glicêmico em diferentes horários né em
diferentes momentos do dia pela manhã e
pela noite e os pesquisadores mediram
como é que seus corpos respondiam a
essas
refeições Então tem um detalhe
interessante aqui eles também levarem
conta se os participantes eram
naturalmente madrugadores ou notívagos
né e os resultados os resultados foram
interessantes houve uma diferença entre
madrugadores para notívagos os
pesquisadores Descobriram que por os
madrugadores aqueles que gostam de
acordar de manhã cedo aqueles que
naturalmente acordam cedo e vão dormir
cedo também para eles comer uma refeição
com alto índice glicêmico pela manhã
resultou em níveis de glicose no sangue
mais baixos após a refeição Então esse
pessoal parece estava mais preparado
para receber a carga glicêmica de manhã
o pessoa que acorda
cedo ok então seus corpos estavam mais
preparados para processar esses
alimentos no início do dia agora o
pessoal que gosta de dmitar de as
corujas né os
notívagos surpreendentemente para esse
grupo que naturalmente fica acordar até
mais tarde acorda mais tarde també tamb
bem não houve diferença significativa
nos níveis de glicose no sangue
Independente de você tá comendo uma
refeição rica em glicose in glicêmico
alto de manhã ou à noite
ok Eles acham que isso se deve ao papel
da
melatonina então a resposta pode estar
no hormônio do Sono os pesquisadores
Descobriram que os níveis de melatonina
pela manhã eram mais altos de maneira
mais significativamente altos nos
notívagos do que nos madrugadores então
o madrugador acordava cedo com
melatonina baixa e o notívago acaba
tendo a melatonina mais alta de manhã
então estudos anteriores mostraram que
níveis mais altos de melatonina podem
prejudicar a tolerância à glicose então
mais
melatonina mais tendência a subir o
açúcar no sangue por isso que não é bom
você comer também tarde da noite porque
a melatonina vai acabar
induzindo que aumente a glicose do
sangue então em outras palavras quando
há mais melatonina circulando no nosso
sistema nosso corpo tem mais dificuldade
de processar os açúcares dos alimentos
Ok então Esse estudo se encaixa em um
quadro maior de pesquisa sobre o nosso
sistema de temporização o cloque Né
circadiano o relógio biológico interno
Então esse sistema controla praticamente
todos os processos biológicos no nosso
corpo incluindo a regulação dos níveis
glicose no
sangue e esse relógio é bem complexo ele
é composto de vários segmentos Tem uma
parte que fica no cérebro e uma parte
que são os relógios secundários fic nos
tecidos nos órgãos ele não é apenas
influenciado pela luz mas também pelo
que nós comemos e quando comemos então
comer fora de sincronia com o relógio
biológico como comer tarde da noite para
os madrugadores
pode levar um desalinhamento cicano que
por sua vez pode afetar negativamente a
saúde metabólica por exemplo a minha
esposa D Ana Paula ela tem mania de
comer tarde da noite e ela é madrugadora
então ela não deveria fazer isso né
Inclusive eu vou até mostrar isso tudo
para ela então as implicações práticas
são essas se você é madrugador coma a
sua refeição que tenha mais índice
glicêmico de manhã cedo se você for do
tipo notívago tá então o notívago não
deve fazer essa refeição de manhã cedo
com índice glicêmico mais alto Ok então
se você é madrugador pode ser benéfico
concentrar suas infeções mais pesadas ou
com maior índice glicêmico no início do
dia porque o corpo do madrugador está
mais bem equipado para lidar com essas
oscilações pros notívagos não é uma
coisa muito ainda conclusiva o estudo
não mostrou uma diferença Clara entre as
refeições matinais e noturnas nesse
grupo mas é importante tomar cuidado né
porque se você for notívago não vá comer
tão tarde da noite porque isso vai
afetar o seu sono a qualidade do sono e
também vai induzir uma resistência ín e
temos que lembrar também que o estudo
foi feito com jovens saudáveis e os
resultados podem ser diferentes para
pessoas mais velhas ou com algum
problema por exemplo pré-diabetes
então no final das contas Esse estudo
nos lembra da complexidade Incrível de
nossos corpos e como os nossos ritmos
naturais podem influenciar a nossa saúde
de maneiras que estamos apenas começando
a entender então embora mais pesquisas
sejam
necessárias e também populações mais
diversas esses resultados destac com a
importância de considerar não apenas o
que comemos Mas também quando
comemos em é importante escutar o seu
corpo prestar atenção aos seus ritmos
naturais porque assim você pode estar
dando um passo importante em direção a
uma melhor saúde
metabólica legal pessoal então o segundo
artigo nós vamos
discutir é sobre um assunto que
interessa a todos nós como a nossa dieta
pode afetar a saúde do fígado então um
estudo recente trouxe à tona algumas
descobertas fascinantes sobre o consumo
de laticínios low carb na verdade low
fat né não locável perdão então o
consumo de laticínios de baixa gordura e
seu impacto na doença hepática gordurosa
não alcoólica e também na
cirrose certo então pesquisadores
decidiram investigasse o consumo de
produtos láctos de baixo te de gordura
Lou fet estaria o não associado menor
risco de desenvolver a doença gordurosa
do fígado e a cirrose então para isso
eles analisaram dados de mais de 0.000
homens e mulheres do uk biobank study a
idade variavel entre 39 e 72 anos então
o estudo acompanhou esses participantes
por um período médio de 12 anos mais
precisamente 11,6 anos então um tempo
bem Interessante que dá uma visão bem
robusta dos efeitos a longo prazo então
estudo interessante pelo tempo longo e
também porque ele
enxergou algumas coisas interessantes
sobre o consumo de Laina em geral tá
lembrando pessoal que eu não recomendo o
consumo de laticínios para maioria das
pessoas A não ser que seja fermentado e
seja um leite orgânico Ok Leite orgânico
fermentado um quefir orgânico mas a
maioria das outras condições eu não
recomendo o estudo Perdão eu não
recomendo o consumo de lactos mas aqui
eu tô dividindo Esse estudo com vocês
que não sinceramente tem a mesma
opinião Então os pesquisadores também
dividiram os produtos em categorias né
os láctos como alto teor de gordura
baixo Teo de gordura fermentado e não
fermentado isso também nos permite ter
uma visão mais detalhada de como
diferentes tipos de laines podem afetar
a saúde
hepática então o estudo revelou que as
pessoas que consumiam mais produtos
láctos de baixo teu de
gordura cerca de 7,5 por por dia tinha
um risco menor 14% menor de desenvolver
a doença hepática gordurosa e
25% Menor desenvolver cirrose em
comparação com aqueles que
consumiam menos porções desse tipo de
produto sem gordura
tá gordura do leite não é boa pessoal
gordura boa é gordura do coco no abacate
nozes e
castanhas azeite de oliva né gordura do
leite tá fora da lista de gorduras boas
inclusive também o as gorduras dos óleos
de semente processados óleos de soja os
de milho canola Girassol esses também
são óleos ruins Margarida também a
gordura hidrogenada que tem no sorvete e
outros produtos
industrializados Então nesse estudo
houve esse achado aí ele mostrou que o
consumo de produtos láctos com baixo te
de gordura
produtos láctos também fermentados
estava associado a um risco menor de
doença urosa do fígado e cirrose Ok
então eu particularmente não recomendo
mas o estudo mostrou que se você for
consumir Leite queijo ou derivados que
utilize um low fat
Ok e o outra coisa interessante nesse
estudo é que eles eles também
compararam se esse consumo de Lin de
baixo teu de gordura era influenciado
pelo perfil genético dos
participantes então eles dividiram
também o o pessoal no grupo com
predisposição genética Alta ou baixa
para doença hepática para acúmulo de
gordura no fígado e parece que o consumo
de laticínio de baixa gordura L fet
oferece Ben íc semelhante PR os dois
grupos o que tem genética desfavorável
ou que tem genética favorável a acumular
gordura no
fígado Esse estudo tem algumas
limitações importantes um deles é que os
pesquisadores utilizaram recordatórios
alimentares ou seja dependeram da
memória das
pessoas de 24 horas para avaliar o
consumo de laines Então pode ter tido
problema por causa disso daí né
dependendo da memória da pessoa
pessa isso é muito comum infelizmente
Porque os estudos que não são assim são
bem mais caros que não usam
questionários são bem mais caros porém
isso pode ter atrapalhado o estudo e
pode não capturar com precisão o consumo
habitual de laticínios de uma pessoa ao
longo do
tempo então não use minha opinião final
sobre isso não use Leite derivados A não
ser que seja casina 2 ou
fermentado Mas se for usar utiliza uma
versão low fet tá com baixo teor de
gordura
certo bem Vamos responder as dúvidas
agora
aqui deixa eu dividir a tela com vocês
as perguntas
pergunta do
Carlos a partir de suas informações a
respeito do uso de azul de metileno que
passei a adotar integralmente e
continuar a eterna busca de resultados
vi o estudo de uso de fotobiomodulação
para auxílio na remoção das proteínas
tal e betamil Loide as quais o azul de
metileno não deixa
agregar coincidentemente tem em casa um
capacete boné desse tipo que minha
mulher usou em tratamento do couro
cabeludo Qual a sua opinião a respeito
bem uma pergunta bem interessante e
assim eu andei dando uma
pesquisada e a combinação sim de
fotobiomodulação e azul de metileno é
uma abordagem promissora ainda tá no seu
início pro tratamento de doenças
neurodegenerativas especialmente a
alheimer a fotobiomodulação pode reduzir
a carga de placa betamil Loide amanhados
tal
né estudos e modelos animais mostraram
que a foto a fotobiomodulação pode
melhorar a função cognitiva e atenuar a
patologia do Alzheimer
melhor a remoção do betamil estimulando
A fagocitose pela células de defesa o
azul de metileno também tem a capacidade
de inibir a agregação de tal e betamil
Loide estudos recentes mostraram que o
azul de metileno pode acelerar a
transição né das gotículas de tal e
inibindo a formação das fibrilas né das
do
amiloides então eles têm um efeito
cinético sim um pode ajudar o outro
enquanto que a fotobiomodulação estimula
a remoção o ul metileno previne novas
agregações Então esse dispositivo que
você comentou aí em forma de
capacete estão sendo utilizados em
estudos e estão sendo também estudados
para uso
doméstico Então seria uma forma
conveniente né uma forma não invasiva
que pode ser utilizado com frequência
em
casa então porém a maioria dos estudos
combinando os dois né azul de metileno
com capacete está ainda em fase
pré-clínica ou pequenos
ensaios Então precisamos esperar mais
tempo para saber se uso combinado né do
azul de metileno com a fotobiomodulação
pode eh ser interessante Então
precisamos estudos mais maiores e
Estudos
clínicos Então eu acho que é uma boa
você fazer isso em casa sim se você
tiver disposto e Mas faça com
acompanhamento médico se for
possível vamos pra próxima pergunta
aqui também do
Carlos sobre o hidrogênio considerando a
questão da liberação de hidrogênio e
oxigênio juntos nos frascos que não tem
orifício de drenagem do Polo positivo
essa liberação de oxigênio na água só é
prejudicial se houver manganês cobre
zinco ferro nío na água ou só o oxigênio
sozinho já é um radical que será
adquirido ou ser ingerido nesse processo
não O problema é que na garrafinha
comum garrafinha que você usa água comum
água eh mineral ou água filtrada tem que
ter o escape do oxigênio se não tiver o
escape do oxigênio esse oxigênio vai
interagir com os outros minerais e
metais e vai ser tóxico OK agora eh um
equipamento que não tem o escape de
oxigênio esse necessariamente tem que
usar água destilada Ok então a diferença
tá na água água comum tem que ter o
escape água destilada não precisa ter o
escape fiquei ainda mais cabreiro quando
vi que esses mesmos equipamentos
produzem hidrogênio e oxigênio
separadamente exigem o uso de água
destilada não é que tá eh água estilada
é fundamental para alguns
equipamentos para que você tenha a
garantia de que não vai formar Essa
parte tóxica aí dos metais tóxicos Ok
então se você usar água destilada é
garantido não precisa de escape de
oxigênio agora no equipamento você vai
usar água comum para beber tem que ter o
escape de oxigênio ficou claro para
você o oxigênio por si só ele não é um
Radical Livre tá Não é esse o problema
então o problema é realmente a interação
do oxigênio molecular com os metais que
possam estar no equipamento então alguns
equipamentos vão ter que usar água
destilada agora a garrafinha não precisa
usar água destilada porque ele tem um
escapo de oxigênio lá por baixo certo eu
acho que deve ter ficado claro para você
mas se não ficou você estando ao vivo
pode
perguntar vamos paraa
próxima Zé Carlos
Pereira a hpb da próstata esse aqui eu
acho que ele se emanan aqui não não
entendi o que ele quis dizer com isso se
você tiver ao vivo
José por
favor me pergunte que se quer saber de
hpb de
próstata Francisco Weber querido amigo
por favor Existe algum benefício em
comer de três em TR horas ao invés de
refeições em maior
quantidade depende tá pra maioria das
pessoas 60 a 70% das pessoas que tem
resistên insulínica comer de três em 3
horas não é uma
boa não é uma boa OK agora algumas
pessoas TM uma característica
interessante se comer com mais
frequência aparentemente Elas têm menos
ansiedade então se a pessoa tem
ansiedade para comer e comer de três em
TR horas ajuda a controlar a ansiedade e
ela não tem resistência insulínica
importante pode ser uma situação aí
indicada de comer de 3 em 3
horas porém a maioria das com menos de
trê em 3 horas acaba comendo caloria
demais e vai aumentar a carga glicêmica
e a resistência
insulínica Esse é um assunto polêmico
tanto que um estudo publicado em 2020
pelo british Journal of Nutrition ainda
ainda recomenda
que se faça uma frequência maior de
refeições que isso estaria associado a
uma melhor qualidade de dieta mas eu não
concordo com
isso então tem um grupo específico
também que é melhor de comer de tr tr
horas fora esse que eu acabei de falar
de pessoas que podem ajudar a controlar
a ansiedade que é o marombeiro né é o
fisiculturista esse esse grupo que
treina pesado Dorme bem e faz todo um
preparo para ganhar massa muscular
faz sentido comer de TR 3 horas que vai
ajudar no no ganho de massa muscular tá
então existe alguns grupos especialmente
aí os fisiculturistas os marombeiros que
vão se beneficiar de comer de TRS em 3
horas só que pra maioria das pessoas eu
não recomendo Eu recomendo que faça
o uma restrição de mais horas sem
comer Rinaldo poderia falar sobre prata
coloidal ouv falar que é muito que
antibióticos Não é bem assim Reinaldo
vou explicar Eesse possível empresa
confiável Então vamos começar com a
confiável Eu recomendo geralmente a alma
cura o site alma cura que eles vendem os
produtos de prata
coloidal existe Muita confusão com prata
coloidal muita polêmica se você procurar
na internet a maioria dos Sites vai
dizer para você que é
tóxico entendeu porque a a prata
coloidal provocaria argiria que é uma
condição que você acumula Sais de prata
no organismo e fica com uma coloração
Azul acidentada azul
assentada na pele que pode ser
Irreversível Porém isso acontece com
produtos que não é prata coloidal real
que na verdade são sais de prata tá
então não recomendo usa sempre um
produto de alta qualidade dá uma cura é
um um realmente uma prata coloidal de
alta qualidade
infelizmente a Agência Nacional de
Vigilância Sanitária nem o fda nem um
Anvisa nem fda aprovam o uso de Plata
coloidal Pode acontecer da Plata
coloidal interferir na absorção de
alguns medicamentos porém eu já vi
estudos mostrando que a prata colid
Poderia ajudar alguns antibióticos Então
isso é meio controverso
também e assim a vantagem da Prata
coloidal que não induz resistência
bacteriana mas ele não é mais eficiente
que os antibióticos tá ele ele é só mais
seguro é menos tóxico Na minha opinião
tá não é que ele é mais eficiente é mais
seguro e menos tóxico e não tem risco de
resistência bacteriana Porém você tem
que utilizar uma prata coloidal de alta
qualidade para isso acontecer se você
usar um produto de qualidade ruim você
pode estar colocando a tua saúde em
risco Boa noite Estela Eliseu Eliana
enilde
[Música]
tá pessoal todo que tá acompanhando ao
vivo
aí Marilda Por que que é dito que não se
deve suimar o Zin S eu falei semana
passada né e sim acompanhado pelo cobre
de novo pessoal não Não façam confusão
se a pessoa tiver zinco alto e cobre
baixo não tem problema nenhum de você
suplimentar o cobre se a pessoa tiver
o
zinco baixo e o cobre alto não tem
nenhum problema de experimentar o zinco
sozinho agora se os dois tiverem baixo
os dois devem ser
repostos Ok vai depender muito da
questão da proporção desequilíbrio Entre
esses dois do organismo se houver um
desequilíbrio do zinco tá muito mais
alto que o cobre ou o cobre muito mais
alto que o zinco não tem problema nenhum
de você suplementar somente um deles
porque ele vai ajudar Inclusive a baixar
o outro que tá alto demais
agora se os dois tiverem embaixo tem que
suplementar os
dois ficou claro para você é simples
isso Marilda não é cência de foguete né
É
simples me diga se você
entendeu para deficiência de Ferro Qual
a melhor forma de suplementar Eu também
já falei semana passada não tô
entendendo porque tá repetindo essas
perguntas aí
né então vou pular fa a pergunta porque
ela tá respondida na na Live
anterior na Live passada você recomendou
tomar a chagan 30 minutos a 1 hora antes
de dormir acontece que a chagan precisa
de
gordura por por solu então se eu tomar a
chagando mais óleo de coco meia hora
antes de dormir eu não estaria quebrando
aquela
regra depende porque se você ingerir só
o óleo de coco é muito pouco calor e não
vai dar pico glicêmico Tá então não há
não é um problema sério você tomar aula
de coco uma hora antes de dormir
não então se você usar o Ach Ganda que
que é uma quantidade pequena junto com a
gordura óleo de coco você não vai est
causando nenhum problema no seu
organismo porque uma colher
de sopa de óleo de coco dificilmente vai
interferir vai dar desconforto digestivo
ou vai dar qualquer problema
metabólico mas você pode também optar
por tomar o Ach Ganda com um pouco de
gordura mais cedo né umas 2 horas ou 3
horas de dormir você pode fazer o
teste respostas individuais podem
variar algumas pessoas a maioria das
pessoas podem tolerar bem um pouco de
gordura antes de dormir agora tem
pessoas que estão mais síveis
provavelmente utilizar o hóa de coco com
Ach Ganda uma hora antes de dormir não
vai interferir na qualidade do seu sono
mas você pode fazer os testes e fazer um
ajuste para mais cedo se for o
caso
a benefício tomar protein antes da
refeição não me lembro se foi você que
disse isso mas nesse caso não vai violar
a regra da ordem de digestão ordem
primeiro vinagre de maçã dois fibras
três gorduras e proteínas e quatro
carboidratos então o benefício de tomar
o e protein antes das refeições é que
estudos mostram que o e Protein aumenta
a
saciedade e vai reduzir a quantidade de
comida que você vai ingerir depois então
pode ajudar a controlar os níveis de
glicos no sangue e aumentar a tua
saciedade
tem um estudo que mostrou que tomar o
protein antes do café da manhã suprimiu
a ingestão de energia no café da manhã
no
almoço a ordem que você mencionou
vinagre de maçã fibras gorduras e
proteínas e
carboidratos é basiada em evidências que
sugerem que essa sequência pode ajudar a
controlar melhor os níveis de glicose a
primeira vista Pode parecer que tenha um
conflito entre tomar o protein antes da
refeição e seguir a ordem recomendada
porém não é um conflito real o Protein
uma proteína de rápida absorção Quando
Você consome antes da refeição ele vai
estar sendo digerido já Quando você
começar a comer os outros alimentos
então o Protein sendo uma proteína se
encaixa na categoria de proteínas na
ordem que você
mencionou E além disso O Protein pode
atuar de forma semelhante as fibras e
proteínas na redução dos picos de
glicose após a refeição então você pode
considerar tomar Protein 15 a 30 minutos
antes da refeição 15 a 30 minutos antes
seguido pelo vinagre de maçã
imediatamente antes de comer e em
seguida você pode continuar nessa ordem
recomendada aí comece com os alimentos
ricos em fibras depois os que tem
gorduras e proteínas e por último os
carboidratos
Ok em um vídeo que você fez H 5 anos
sobre quantos ovos deve comer por dia
você diz que o ovo possui perfil de
aproveitamento de aminoácido superior da
Carne sim is nós falamos disso semana
passada né carne frango e proteí e
outras proteínas isso quer dizer que não
existe nenhum alimento com maior
aproveitamento de aminoácidos tem tem
tem sim que é qu dizer dos que a gente
come habitualmente É sim é é o ovo que é
o melhor né que tem esse aproveitamento
melhor mas o leite materno no bebê é
melhor que o ovo tá esse aproveitamento
de aminoácido significa maior absorção
não significa melhor
aproveitamento maior processamento em
geral não é só
absorção vamos ver aqui as perguntas ao
vivo para mamãe que quer amamentar Sea
bebê mas não consegue produzir Leite ela
pode substituir o leite de peito pelo
Leite cabra em algumas circunstância Sim
tem muita pediatra que faz isso e também
pelo leite de coco também são opções tá
tem leite de arroz tem várias opções
você pode utilizar são boas opções sim
mas sempre acompanhamento de um Pediatra
tá concentração de 50% de fenos ídeos no
suplemento feno grego é excelente sim é
bom sim é muito bom extrato de 95% de
procianidina no suplemento picnogenol é
excelente sim
quem provoca coágulos do sangue k1 ou K2
é muito mais a k1 ela é quatro vezes
mais potente do que a K2 nesse quisito
mas a K2 também pode participar da
coagulação novamente Boa noite a todos
que estão
acompanhando É verdade que o leite da
vaca casina A1 é ruim e o casina A2 é
saudável sim a casina A1 é inflamatório
o A2 é bem menos problemático tá já
falei isso em vídeos na no canal do
YouTube tá Dá uma checada lá no nos
vídeos que eu falo sobre
isso para quem tem refluxo o único a
Protein que serve é o hidrolizado não
necessariamente tá o hidrolizado é mais
recomendado para pessoas que têm
dificuldade de gestão quer dizer não é
não quer dizer que essa pessoa tem que
ter refluxo também pode ser e é provável
que a pessoa que tem digestão ruim vai
ter refluxo mas n é todo mundo que tem
refluxo tem digestão
ruim então o que eu recomendo hoje em
dia paraa maioria das pessoas ele dizer
ou é o o Way tá isolado ou é a
combinação do isolado com o hidrolizado
né esses way 3w que eles falam que é
concentrado isado e
isolado eu não usaria paraa maioria das
pessoas tá se for um cara muito jov
e que tá fazendo musculação pesada não
vai fazer muita diferença o concentrado
não vai fazer muito mal mas eu
particularmente na minha idade ou PR
maioria das pessoas Eu recomendo usar o
isolado ou a combinação do isolado com
hidrolizado certo pessoal mais perguntas
eu acho que tem mais um artigo que a
gente
pode discutindo aqui
sobre dieta
mediterrânea vocês querem que eu fale
mais um artigo sobre dieta mediterrânea
ou ou vocês querem que eu continuo
respondendo
perguntas que que vocês querem que eu
faça deixamos esse artigo pra semana que
vem ou a gente fala desse artigo agora
aqui fermento Royal é um produto
alimentício certo Royal é uma marca né
Eu acho que o Royal não é só um tipo de
fermento acho que é uma marca que tem
mais de um tipo
tá mas não tenho
certeza Duas Taças de vinho por dia
provoca coágulos no sangue não não
provoca não ok pra maioria das pessoas é
tolerável tomar Duas Taças de vinho por
dia comer fígado bovina uma vez por
semana já é suficiente para ter boas
quantidades de
12 na maioria das vezes sim mas tem
gente que vai ter dificuldade de
absorção três quatro pessoas já estão
falando que querem mais um artigo Que
bom que não encho o saco de vocês com
esses artigos
né Vamos lá
então o próximo artigo é sobre um
assunto que é muito popular que é dieta
mediterrânea um estudo recente
mostrou que a dieta mediterrânea pode
ser uma aliada para quem
sofre da mesma doença que a gente estava
comentando antes que a doença hepática
gordurosa não
alcoólica Então vamos ver como que o
azeite as azeitonas e outros tesouros
dessa dieta podem estar ajudando muito
na nossa saúde inclusive do
fígado então pesquisadores decidiram
investigar se seguir uma dieta
mediterrânea poderia melhorar a saúde
das pessoas com doença hepática
gordurosa não alcoólica eles analisaram
dados de 40 participantes com idade
entre 40 e 60 e todos eles viviam na
Espanha o estudo durou 2 anos e é um
estudo aí um tempo razoável que dá para
chegar a umas conclusões
interessantes então Além de olhar para
mudanças no peso corporal e na gordura
do fígado os pesquisadores também
analisaram uma série de biomarcadores de
saúde Cardi metabólica então incluía
coisas como nível de glicose no sangue
pressão arterial e marcadora de estresse
oxidativo um checkup
completo Então como não é nada
surpreendente para vocês né a dieta
mediterrânea se tornou se mostrou uma
aliada do
fígado então o estudo revelou que as
pessoas que aderiram mais fortemente a
dieta mediterrânea tiveram resultados
melhores perderam mais mais peso e
também tiveram melhoras significativas
na saúde do
fígado e não foi só o fígado que se
beneficiou como vocês devem estar se
imaginando né os participantes que
seguiram a dieta mediterrânea com mais
afinco também viram Melhoras e
marcadoras de estresse oxidativo e
status antioxidante então a dieta deu um
Boost no sistema de defesa do corpo
contra danos
celulares Então os participantes que
aderiram mais a dieta mediterrânea
tiveram reduções de peso maiores
reduções também no índice de massa
corporal e na gordura do fígado e
melhoras num biomarcador chamado
citoqueratina 18 que nem tem nos
Laboratórios comerciais e esse marcador
aí que eu não conhecia é um indicador de
saúde do fígado então reduziu a tal da
citoqueratina 18 e isso foi uma
demonstração que a saúde do fígado
melhorou o grupo que teve maior lesão
adat Terrâneo teve melhora também nas
enzimas antioxidantes catalase
superóxido dismutase glutationa redutase
e glutationa Total nas células vermelhas
do
sangue e também os níveis de malon de
aldeído que é um macado tem alguns
Laboratórios especiais Esse malon de
aldeído aí não é fácil de achar mas
existe Então nesse pessoal usando a
dieta mediterrânea né com mais afinco o
de aldeído o marcador de estresse
oxidativo caiu então só teve coisa boa
aí na dieta mediterrânea então adotar
uma dieta desse tipo pode ser uma
estratégia poderosa para quem luta
contra a doença hepática gordurosa não
alcoólica ajuda a perder peso Reduzir a
gordura no fígado e aumentar o sistema
antioxidante do
corpo Lembrando que esse estudo foi só
com pessoas que moram na Espanha os
resultados são encorajadores Mas pode
não ser igual para outras populações
exatamente iguais né Tem gente que acha
por exemplo que a dieta tem que ser de
acordo com os ancestrais se você tem
ancestral espanhol por exemplo poderia
ser uma boa dieta mas se você tiver uma
ancestral sei lá da Turquia que Turquia
não é um bom exemplo porque também tá na
região do Mediterrâneo né Vamos pensar
assim um cara que mora no Japão né então
talvez a dietamente ter
segundo tem aí essa visão de algumas
pessoas não seria a melhor dieta para um
japonês ou para quem etnicamente é um
japonês porque ele não é ancestralmente
da região do Mediterrâneo mas eu não
tenho certeza disso né Isso é só uma
ideia de alguns grupos
aí então vamos acrescentar mais azeite
de oliva extravirgem vegetais coloridos
mais peixes mais nozes e castanhas a
nossa alimentação
mas grãos também de alta qualidade grãos
integrais porque o seu fígado e o resto
do seu corpo vai agradecer
certo
bem Tem uma última pergunta aqui do
Eliseu que eu vou responder mas eu acho
que eu vou encerrar com 40 minutos de
Live pessoal 1 g de creatina por dia
durante um jejum de 5 dias além de não
quebrar o jejum também bloqueia a
sarcopenia
Boa pergunta eu acho que vai eh bloquear
assim parcialmente essa cenia mas não
vai chegar a bloquear 100% não tá elizu
porque na verdade o a creatina não é
proteína a creatina é uma forma de
armazenar energia no organismo mas se
você ficar cinco dias sem comer proteína
nenhuma nem carboidrato de boa qualidade
eu acho que isso vai ser muito difícil
se você não ter sarcopenia mas a
sarcopenia também que vai ser bem
temporária se você voltar pra
alimentação depois
né de modo geral não recomendo o uso de
leite derivados
tá e você pode se você gostar muito de
leite derivados você utiliza a forma
fermentada ou queijo curado ou ainda usa
um um Laino do tipo casina
2 bem pessoal obrigado aí pela audiência
de vocês nós nos vemos na semana que vem
um grande abraço um beijo no coração